okay okay we're back in we're back in um
we're gonna act the right bebe's act the
way I can't scary [ __ ] [ __ ] loud
character a house is built of walls and
beams the home was built of fears and
dreams take any cool what is this dad
what is [ __ ] orbiting now that's over
T okay that's a anything antique over
here now just say mouth shut
yeah oh my god I like that I like that
oh I got to see if I get another
treasure was it is it all don't like
look through the [ __ ] in here this is
fun okay
what is that
that mine yet we got it baby
we got it
yeah I guess I kinda want this this is
usually we're up to go right okay all
right let's say what's next okay yeah
yeah let's do this batch extra bibbing
acting yeah hello nice pecs where's a
bit of shooting button not too bad give
me a [ __ ] coffee I'm an actor I don't
really know like science sir
okay that's fine
okay I get a lot of the lines memorize
that this can hurry up a little bit okay
okay act 3 or a III if you can't read
that correctly no I wrote her here
I know I've my ugly panting like there's
like a very slight sway I'd say but the
character look with any contact Beckham
burped me in the present rooted in the
past okay let's play it that's good oh
great I have to [ __ ] go through the
pain again
yeah oh oh all right yeah we got babies
whoa [ __ ] oh it's okay okay sorry it's
been a while for a while yeah look at
that
[ __ ] mess a [ __ ] disgusting no one
has any [ __ ] it's just makes me sad
is that
but how does it do that a secant if it's
in there step it [ __ ]
its strength its calm its freedom that's
what she's that
okay okay
and I can't treasures in here
you know I like to show the [ __ ]
flashlight right tiny I'm [ __ ] bikini
yeah it is big whoa this place is very
disorienting holy [ __ ]
everything's [ __ ] crooked okay Sam
okay everything's so [ __ ] dizzy
well
why is everything so [ __ ] crooked
forgive that stick out with mr. brown
now
[ __ ] you protecting me look at this
design it's [ __ ] dope I got tile you
did okay let's see here now
are we sending over a new reel tomorrow
pirate film or the inks like a good spin
okay catch and don't mind if I tell
okay let's go this kitchen I feel like
I'm [ __ ] sure to [ __ ] cuz all the
walls we [ __ ] up oh this is how it
starts it's gonna close on me
don't you think if you over there yeah
[Music]
barley the kid in there a whole lot uh
he's funny
let's [ __ ] are they gonna make me put in
there I'm an actor I don't cook I
[ __ ] know we're gonna go up the [ __ ]
is that
I don't like how tiny I am
there's this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
Armand hello sir
shit's getting [ __ ] stormy in here
okay I'd say yeah how's it nice claimed
are fine great
okay see coming towards me
the [ __ ] is he doing
okay if I have you torn up by conflict
Bob it's a [ __ ] dog
alright [ __ ] running I can rot in
hell you come this way though except put
the like in all right put the brain in I
guess there's more get it down
okay guess I'm done here
hmm a little [ __ ] okay and I could
really just say goodbye to my
monetization mr. right
oh yeah that's that's sad all right
the [ __ ] is that okay
oh [ __ ] it erotic rod betcha Ron [ __ ]
Ron
okay put the [ __ ] in here put this [ __ ]
in here yep I'm a chef
oh that's a gray okay what was that man
is this the [ __ ] Wizard of Oz
sometimes I'm gonna have to get that
[ __ ] [ __ ] run all right guys just a
so judges who had some scary [ __ ]
movies almost over time to go that's
gonna be some scary [ __ ] pretty sound
okay please about the noises up in the
balcony
he pushed against Timmy's gonna fall on
her bloody had somebody keep it off
limits damn thing can barely support it
sound white now that sounds like your
problem not mine so you can I'm just an
actor what is that
let's select the Wizard of Oz in there
how about chicken egg lever that is a
lever
the [ __ ] is that don't step into that
light or LCA what the [ __ ] is that
whoa that [ __ ] slammed on me I say yeah
I don't like being so short
how's that going
you slide
his mouth is disgusting because he lacks
proper dental hygiene
close their mouth
oh you got to put it on this batch I
said you were always bad luck I give
everything in return stare a gratitude
little hot is that too much to ask I
guess so my nice up my sleeve that's all
I need an ace up his sleeve a lucky
break a nice up my sleeve that's all I
need
Dalila the top woman she likes toys a
lot trying to put an ace up her sleeve
okay
so it's more gonna do so it's nothing I
got to get like something in this world
to help him out in that world a lucky
break
I'll hit break I got I got the ACE pitch
you have to find it you have to take it
back okay we got it
lucky break nice my sleeve that's all I
need
hey they got where they get by that's
[ __ ] okay
oh [ __ ] this is scary what is happening
here
Jesus okay
Oh what the [ __ ] that baby's on the
[ __ ] ceiling now find it bring it
back bring it back what miss a mass find
it bring it back bring it back
I'm gonna put it back
I take the card now
I'm not exactly sure what happens now
now there's got to be like one more spot
this is a clue
that [ __ ]
hmmm let's see here
this is [ __ ] puzzling
I feel like now that is a tasteless
leave there's like [ __ ] I got to do here
it's like a [ __ ]
this is a chance now
just take it back no the only one not
[ __ ] solved is this one I think
[ __ ] scary [ __ ] looking find it
[ __ ] look at what am I trying to find
find it bring it back
find it bring it back
find it bring it back
the [ __ ] can I try to find okay
so I have to get the ace of spades back
[ __ ] bring it back okay that means
it's gotta be in this one
oh there we go
okay that was easy that's it yeah that's
here yeah shut your [ __ ] mouth [ __ ]
that man
so door now
disgusting sure whining
and there will be again scary
[ __ ] happening the basement all right
yeah incest yeah I don't like being
right here cuz apparently that's where
that crazy psycho is right that's right
then you see if they have lighter
something
yeah where you got boys I don't think
it's in here
yeah that's that light [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
badass
basement
we look for a place to hide
the job can be many things
- [ __ ] I put in there okay
what the [ __ ] every [ __ ] head sir I
gotta take
it is whatever it's [ __ ] disgusting
this is [ __ ] disgusting holy [ __ ] I
was spending on sweaty I'm sweaty
oh [ __ ] where'd it go
the [ __ ] erotic [ __ ] it running early
[ __ ]
like [ __ ] [ __ ] hide it in here I
don't give a [ __ ] that's [ __ ] scary
here we go babies [ __ ] get in [ __ ] see
there [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ah right yeah we
met summer or something at which head is
it this one Dinah yeah strong stop stop
look nice on today's okay let's see here
[ __ ] that's Carrie the [ __ ] Anna Mae oh
now why'd you want to go to such it
hush it's already started yeah take a
look the [ __ ] that guy's not even
[ __ ] paying attention come on okay no
it's actually nice in here now
okay thanks Ange Ange [ __ ] turret
[ __ ] scary that [ __ ] is stomping
around
so that's recording [ __ ]
sir
okay
get away from me
pay me my way - holy [ __ ] take what up
the tables have turned quartermaster
curse you and your mutinous well I will
not make this easy for you
if I am to meet my doom today it will be
by your hands let's get this brow - it
you wanted to be like me well yeah you
thought you could be me you always be
whoa holy [ __ ] that a real [ __ ] chick
that's a real [ __ ] chick
I gotta say this body ah it's mr. markey
I shot you in the [ __ ] face what the
[ __ ] is that a real person cares right
I'll dress that bench
all right
five laughs [ __ ] am i I'm my face [ __ ]
and now you [ __ ] paying attention
no we've seen this already
she sounds [ __ ] the office I always
get hit by that thing I see this
st. change yeah yeah you know I mean so
there's a new every single time as I
missed one that
yeah that [ __ ] still like flying around
let's see here
Oh
- the helmsman he loves gold above all
our secrets Mota foresters ship to his
treasure okay
don't focus that yeahokay
scaring me
I miss been missing a lot
yeah we're [ __ ] over here I like
building a [ __ ] rocket yeah okay any
other piece
so [ __ ] middle part I must be huge
right
I got it
okay now I can launch that [ __ ] [ __ ]
what I'm missing
make a shopping
oh hey [ __ ] this [ __ ] in the sauces
[ __ ]
there's that man am i flying away whoa
sometimes when darkness fell across town
you'd sneak out of the house you'd look
up into the night sky watching the stars
but never really seen
what he really saw was a thousand souls
on fire this has bet his eyes would
light up the stars were already there at
that moment I knew he had to make a
thousand hearts bleed a thousand heads
turn a thousand eyes weep my brother
silent dreamer
dreaming that a day would come okay yes
he had it in him to make thousand souls
but make them feel alive make them live
is my part I felt like I that facia it's
[ __ ] ugly okay nice and my log back
when we could take it
yeah what the [ __ ] is that
something vicious
they say
whoa that's crazy
there's some crazy animation I'm like
you know I'm gonna pit [ __ ] buried my
[ __ ] a good things a door right here
yeah no I won't you take a real say
today me that time
scene change yeah how does that
and I thank you
should [ __ ] up [ __ ]
this different er same one at Bert's
okay
that's all the doors are slowly boarded
out
okay
[ __ ]
I don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
okay
I don't know oh so I could see
it's raining there say I turn this off
what are these heads
so
isn't that like satisfied and he's a
little bit uh he's happy now here we go
nice and strong
like daddy okay
take a melon
shine tip with that stupid melon is
blocking I blow it away
now little water right
now he can grow and grow and grow
huh dan is a computers now
the [ __ ] was that
inspection the fire safety 30 days just
got this 30-day that fire stall them
alright yes step it [ __ ] doctorate
don't set this place on fire place place
are now there's long bench yeah I was
interesting enough now
this gas thing
that's out of dirty way to go
is he gonna do it or something
okay you gonna hide oh I guess that
means you die
yes they would [ __ ]
run batch for run
well
okay I'm safe in here baby
am I supposed to be going yeah I guess
this is the way
I can't tell where the [ __ ]
so quiet in here
casting
ah [ __ ]
I'm running [ __ ] we're all these fish
doing here
[ __ ] run run [ __ ]
yeah wait till it goes this way hell
yeah baby
just run [ __ ] run [ __ ] shut [ __ ]
dick on a stick what does that man
did you get anything for James
it's his day too
take it chef
yeah you are dumb the [ __ ] is that
hey Dad
you're disgusting
now you're making my head hurt come on
there's nothing that faucet can we do
anything for the guy
I say sorry sorry yeah yes stupid [ __ ]
yeah I still watching that thing spirits
isn't a dream or all my father's lost
the weakness which I feel
okay let's say what were you gotta go
let's say what were you get it down see
yeah there's not a toy or anything on
the ground so [ __ ] is that other record
we talkin gross guy like [ __ ] well
okay
'we did at my ChaCha's way that great
[ __ ] money
Hubbs right now well this guy's the
[ __ ] that take a bird with [ __ ]
flying out of it this place is crazy now
character go all the way
I got a bunch more clips now
okay oh [ __ ]
I [ __ ] that [ __ ] and I [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
wait I think there's an order
so one two three I'm missing [ __ ] I'm
missing [ __ ] two
this is dumb rod to keep president go
now I'm until you show up with ascetic
advantage tricks you please down for
tunnel today he'll be right your friend
agent
oh it needs water
cat
I know it bad that
okay I see the [ __ ] mess in here I
wear the [ __ ] where my services see
what that's around here what do I never
get this that's what I need to collect
I'll see if I can swear kitties
okay yeah so it's like the birds upside
down now the [ __ ] let's see what [ __ ] we
got we got some good classics yeah I
don't really get that I did [ __ ]
great no one could say anything
otherwise
I went to save directors notes the
character turning-point test back
breathe remember no chains both life
scars it to find them okay alright well
thanks for watching you I'll help you
all how to get episode and see the next
side okay